[Musique]
bonjour mon coeur depuis que je suis
toute petite mes cheveux ses taux pour
moi j'avais besoin d'être arrêté c'est
seulement à ce moment-là que je devenais
marne
qu'est ce que tu as dit parfait vous
nous montrez beau travail
ce soir ce sera le plus beau moment de
ma vie
qu'est ce que je pourrais offrir à la
femme parfaite
je vous présente lola
je m'attendais à ce que tu m'offres une
bague tu m'as dit que j'étais parfaite
la perfection non-stop
tu ne te laissent jamais aller il a
choisi quelqu'un d'autre
tu pourrais parrainer genre six enfants
ougandais avec ce que tu dépenses pour
tes cheveux ont fait des excuses à ma
fille elle sait mieux que vous quoi sois
toi même
regardez-moi ça la coupe maniaco coincé
de madame parfaite ou les extensions de
la fille avec qui on s'ennuie perso j'ai
adoré des extensions j'ai fait tellement
d'efforts pour être parfait ça n'a pas
suffi
[Musique]
mama
tu crois que tu as fait ça comme ça sur
un coup de tête
moi je crois que c'est venu crescendo
tu es une fille unique chloé
ou est ce que tu vas je vais dîner
tu sais ce que les hommes veulent ils
veulent de vraies femmes
mon père ne pas me taire de permanents
il est très bien comme tu es c'est de la
folie il faut que ça s'arrête
c'est exact c'est vrai
mes cheveux c'était comme un deuxième
boulot maintenant je dois me concentrer
sur d'autres facettes de ma personnalité
je me demande qui je vais devenir